[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am sitting today with betty
pezzamenti who is a caterer from
melbourne australia she is the founder
and co-owner of the earthly sweet spot
now this is not the usual dark horse
podcast betty reached out to me and told
me a story about what is taking place
with her in australia and i must say i
was flabbergasted by what i heard it was
almost impossible to believe i looked
into the story and to the extent that i
was capable of assessing it it appears
to be absolutely true
so betty welcome to dark horse
um i'd like you to tell the audience
what you told me about what you're
facing
yeah
i've read thank you for the opportunity
to be on here
um and for taking up my story
um so
essentially
given what's going on in australia
um
with the vaccine mandates
in our home state in victoria
as of two weeks ago it was mandated that
every profession essentially
to be able to work and participate in
most areas of society you needed to
either have a double vaccination status
of one of the three available vaccines
or
have a legal exemption
given by your doctor and are your
vaccines in australia the same ones that
we have in the states
so we have um both the mrna so we've got
the pfizer and the moderna um but we do
not have the johnson and johnson we have
um
uh astrazeneca which seems to be like on
a component level it seems to be fairly
similar um into what it contains
um so a way to obtain
a uh exemption is to have a
contraindication to one
uh
to
having like a pre-existing issue say as
an anaphylactic reaction to one of the
excipients or components of any of the
the vaccines
that condemn you eligible for a
permanent
exemption to getting the vaccinations
um so i was clinically diagnosed six
years ago with a polyethylene glycol or
pegs for short
another name for it is macro goal
um excipient um i have allergies to an
anaphylaxis to a multitude of things um
but the excipients being one of the
worst so this had been diagnosed and
documented
um
this component is actually
in the mrna vaccination so both the
physio and moderna it's also chemically
similar to another component called
polysorbate 80 which um is present in
both the
johnson johnson and the astrozenica
vaccinations so there is a high
probability of cross-reactivity if you
have the polyethylene glycol
anaphylactic
allergy as well so you have you have a
condition in which you will have an
allergic reaction to one of the
components in the two mrna vaccines and
are likely to have a reaction
to
a component in the third vaccine to
which you have a
access now are these the only things
that you are uh prone to have an
allergic reaction to
no they're not um i do have
a
anaphylactic allergies to other items i
have a multitude of allergies but the
anaphylaxis
is to other excipients as well another
one being
magnesium stearate
which is in like a multitude of things
so supplements food items um as well
polyethylene glycols are also in most um
beauty products fun um even skin care
products and that
um
so i've also got anaphylaxis to certain
foods so kiwi fruit um
avocado
they're some of the main culprits
i have recently recently reacted um
to
other ingredients that are unknown which
i'm getting investigated currently
um it does seem to be preservatives and
also other excipients that are contained
in pharmaceuticals as well um but we
haven't pinpointed my my healthcare team
hasn't pinpointed exactly what but i do
have the diagnosis for the other items
and is there a is there an overarching
condition that's been identified
um so i have been
um diagnosed with a connective tissue
disorder that was this year
um
it's called ehlers-danlos syndrome
um
whether that is sort of the thing that
has
i guess been the underlying condition to
create any of these allergies i'm not
too sure
um there does seem to be an issue with
alice danlos syndrome and um mast cell
activation syndrome sort of seems to tie
into it but it's still sort of ill
what i've been told is it's early days
within the research they don't really
know how it all sort of intertwines
um
but usually someone with
the connective tissue disorder does seem
to have
multiple allergies or high reactivity to
things especially
pharmaceuticals and excipients
also another issue can be um
like things like opioid resistance or um
like anesthetic resistance as well
and so you've had anaphylactic reactions
i have yeah i've had multiple
and what happens
yep um so
generally it comes up in sort of like a
hive rash to begin with um that's
i guess each is quite different
depending on um
if it's something i've used topically it
generally starts as a hive type of rash
if it's something i've ingested
generally it starts in my mouth so if
it's like a tablet or something like
that
it's um
first appeared sort of like tongue
swelling lip swelling
itchy throat then my airways start to
close up and then it might i might break
out into hives
um if it's topical generally it'll start
with the hives and then kind of do a
reverse reaction so then it'll start
going into my throat my lips my tongue
um
i have had anaphylaxis
from
also
uh
having an injection before it wasn't a
vaccination it was a cortisone injection
actually that was a different experience
that was my most severe anaphylactic
reaction i actually lost consciousness
twice um
that i just didn't feel well and then i
lost consciousness i passed out um
when i came to it was my body had broken
out into hives all over the throat
tightness couldn't breathe
um couldn't see
i was administered epinephrine which is
the epipen
which i lost consciousness again after
that um
when i came to i was vomiting um
and then i was taken to the er for
monitoring as well post that
and so um
fair to say that these reactions are
a threat to your life and that
uh intervention is is necessary to
protect you
yeah definitely um i after an
anaphylactic reaction regardless of
being administered epinephrine
um
you you have to go to hospital you have
to be monitored because you can actually
have a resurgence even if the
um after whether it is the epinephrine
is
used or not if your symptoms
i guess lessen it can actually resurge
so you generally have to go into
hospital for 12 hours for monitoring for
this reason
um and sometimes one dose epinephrine
isn't enough as well
um i've also been after an anaphylactic
reaction i was administered
um
types of antihistamines and also another
pharmaceutical fenergon
which also contained the components that
i'm anaphylactic to so it exacerbated my
allergic reaction and i was also
administered epinephrine that time as
well
and uh
am i correct that epinephrine itself is
a hazard that the shock to the system uh
is potentially dangerous
yeah um
i'm like personally i don't know too
much about how it could impact other
areas of the body
um
anytime i've had it administered though
it's literally made me feel like i'm
about to jump out of my skin my heart
starts racing it's induced nausea
um
like i said after that a
severe reaction where i lost
consciousness after the dose of
epinephrine i actually lost
consciousness again so whether that was
also due to the epinephrine i'm not sure
um
there is also um you can also have an
issue where you're anaphylactic to
epinephrine
[Music]
which again never been tested for and i
would really hope that that wouldn't be
something that i would also experience
but it is likely that that can actually
be an allergen i must say uh it's
um
it's marvelous to see that you actually
have a sense of humor about this i guess
you would have to but
uh it's shocking as someone who doesn't
face this just imagining what it must be
like
to live with sensitivity
to things that don't trouble other
people and to never know when you're
going to encounter them and and
therefore when when your life will
suddenly be
in jeopardy is a it's a shocking thought
and uh anyway it's you're obviously
handling it very well but um
is
i don't know even how to ask this
assuming that you have a an anaphylactic
reaction
and uh there's medical care available
as far as you know is it guaranteed to
work
no no it it could work
um epinephrine is our best chance of
survival with an anaphylactic reaction
however it's not guaranteed to work
all right so uh i mean of course i know
your story but it would seem
that if anybody
had justification for an exemption from
a mandate
it would have to be you
you are sensitive at the level that it
will produce an anaphylactic reaction
to a component of two of the vaccines
you are sensitive to a wide number of
things making any injection a risk
and the third vaccine to which you have
access has a component to which you
might be cross-reactive so
fair to say that it would clearly put
your life in jeopardy to take one of
these vaccines
yeah definitely yeah
uh what happened when you
uh went to the doctor and said i can't
take these uh i need an exemption
yeah so given that our mandates were
coming in and every um occupation being
on the mandate list i was like well if i
don't have my exemption i legally can't
work
in
the state of victoria
um now that's also gone across
nationwide so there's not any state i
would be able to
over the next few months given the
mandates and again you are you are a
caterer working out of
a
catering vehicle
so yeah into this is not
uh a situation where you're
tending to patients indoors and enclosed
spaces you're
working pretty close to outdoors with
respect to your interface with anybody
else and yet you can't work without uh
proof of vaccination
no i can't even if i'm in the space by
myself and even if it's a door down
operation and i'm just literally even
doing
click and collect or contactless um
delivery
i'm still
not legally allowed to work
um in my home state all right and i
interrupted you were going to tell me
what happened when you uh you went to
your doctor to ask for the exemption
that you were obviously due
yeah so i i went to my gp who
knows my history um
she
i have quite an extensive history so my
file is quite a big one if say i were to
take to a new specialist or a new doctor
um
so i went to her just thinking it'll be
an easy process it's stipulated on
multiple government websites so if
you've got a contraindication and a
polyethylene specifically a polyethylene
glycol
excipient allergy and the high
possibility of polysorbate 80 cross
reactivity
you can be granted a permanent exemption
to the covert vaccinations
so
given that this was stipulated on um
multiple websites in australia the um
the
victorian specialist immunization
services the melbourne vaccination
education center's website um i know
even globally it's been mentioned on the
cdc website and numerous ones as well
um
it's also uh stipulated on the
australian immunization registrar um the
form which is the form that the doctors
fill out that gets sent to our medicare
to be able to be granted this
permanent exemption so i went to my
doctor asking her to fill out this form
it's called the im011 form
she returned to me with saying
i can't give you the exemption due to
legal liability
wow
that's that's incredible
all right so
i i still can't quite wrap my mind
around any system that has so little
discretion in it that someone whose
story is as clear as yours and for whom
the jeopardy is as severe as the
jeopardy that you face
can't get an exemption
presumably
uh
you didn't take
no for an answer
um
what else has happened
well since that i was quite
i was quite perplexed by that it didn't
seem to make any sense that she would
have
she said that she couldn't grant me an
exemption due to legal liability
um it's also stipulated on all these
websites the people that can
administer an exemption are general
practitioners clinical immunologists
obstetricians gynecologists
pediatricians
um
so it was like well clear as day to me
i've got the contraindication you're my
general practitioner you know this
you're my trading doctor why can't you
submit this form
and she just kept saying that no i can't
there's too many legalities around it
and then she also said to me the only
people that can
were a clinical immunologist
so from there i
asked for a referral to my previous
clinical immunologist which was through
a public health care system at a public
hospital
these were the people who actually
diagnosed me six years ago with the
polyethylene glycol allergy
um
i got back a letter from the hospital
saying that the weight would be 12 to 24
months before i could see a clinical
immunologist
wow
so uh you know i must say i obviously
knew your story before we started
talking each time i hear it i find
myself newly
shocked
and enraged
i mean
we have
two amazing facts already on the table
one the idea that legal liability
actually
causes someone not to want to give you
the exemption
which is of course
the exact inverse of what you would
expect right the fact that your life
will be placed in jeopardy by taking
such a vaccination if there's any place
where there should be
legal liability it would be that a
practitioner that failed to give you the
exemption is putting your life in in
jeopardy and yet
there is some other kind of jeopardy
that frightens this practitioner
even more
and then as you go to the authority that
you're told is the only authority who
can grant the exemption
you're told it will take 12 months did
you say
12 to 24 months yeah
a year to two years during which time
you will not be able to work
wouldn't be able to work and participate
in like many facets of society as well
so you would basically
lose
fundamental rights including the right
to earn a living
because you can't get an exemption
that frankly anyone should understand is
absolutely justified
this is um i mean it's tragic and it's
also
in some sense a measure of just how
dysfunctional the west has become
you know i i know
australia is in some sense ahead of
the curve with respect to authoritarian
measures with response to covid but
this is just
it's a
it's a stunning
rejection of the idea of a functional
system it's the inverse of a functional
system
all right so you to you were told you
would take 12 to 24 months to get the
exemption that would then allow you to
return
to work
what happened next
so i went back to my doctor and told her
this is the correspondence i received um
from the hospital it was in written
letter form um
[Music]
earlier to this i also have a
private pain specialist um he is who i
see for um about my alice danlos
syndrome and other conditions
he had noted he was the first one to
actually note that there might be marcel
activation
issues
um
and that he would recommend me to see a
private clinical immunologist
so i asked my doctor if she could refer
me to him thinking possibly the weight
could be a lot shorter um i just thought
given that my history had been with this
other hospital was probably best to go
see them however i'm happy to go private
right because the other hospital
because they diagnosed the condition in
the first place before their before
covet existed
they obviously know that you couldn't
possibly be making this up
right i mean no one has better evidence
of that than that hospital and yet and
yet they couldn't see the necessity of
getting you
an exemption i mean frankly a piece of
paper that just simply
stops this
train in motion
it's incredible
exactly yeah so i um i requested to see
a a private specialist who i've never
seen before
um
which i found out that the wait to see
them would be 11 months
um yeah
i i i
i have to ask you this betty
is there any way
that you're just
being too nice when people tell you
these
incredible things are are you saying to
them are you looking them in the eye and
are you saying
i am a human being i am entitled not to
have my livelihood destroyed and my life
put in jeopardy and you're telling me i
have to wait a year or more in order to
even see the specialist who can write
the exemption can you please help me
have you said something like that
with my i guess my main point of call is
being my general practitioner um
and
to hear her say that she couldn't grant
me an
exemption was quite shocking
then to find out these wait times
i thought no i just need to go back to
her and i need to reiterate how
important this is
um
so i did once i found out about this
weight and i thought i'm going to do
this again
and i don't care that she said no the
first time i'm going to ask
um
possibly i have been quite nice and not
maybe as assertive
previously i guess prior to this i
didn't think there would be any issue of
me gaining an exemption it just seemed
very clear-cut that i was going to be
the perfect candidate
to gain an exemption given my history
um and what has been stipulated
everywhere on the government websites
and the health websites that i thought
oh this is easy for people like me
um especially given that it's been noted
that a polyethylene glycol excipient
allergy is a very rare case
um
not to mention across all of our
media platforms our mainstream media
platforms
the constant message
being
said is
not everyone can get vaccinated
and
essentially people like myself so the
ones who can't get vaccinated are being
used
in this way um
call it propaganda if you will but they
are literally saying
get vaccinated for those who can't
yes this is this is also my thought is
it would seem
[Music]
the propaganda here too
says look not everybody is lucky enough
to be able to accept this vaccine not
everyone can take it it is the
obligation of those who can to do it for
the vulnerable
who can't
now if the system
is not giving you an exemption if it
doesn't understand you as somebody in
need of protection
presumably from both covid and the
vaccines
then who is this for
who are we protecting if not you
exactly and that's why all this
exemption process just seemed to make no
sense to me because it just felt like
well what what is the good of the
exemptions
if they're not granting them
for people like me or it is near
impossible to be granted this
so i returned to my doctor and requested
again i said look
the mandates are coming in that was that
week i said the mandates are coming in
this week
i cannot legally earn a living
um
i was also told that i may not be able
to um
see my psychologist in person
due to this so i'm also being denied
access
to other health industries um
there are some doctors that are refusing
to see patients
um especially face to face they're doing
tele health but face to face if they're
not vaccinated
um you're being denied access to
important aspects of civilization
including
health care
by virtue of the fact that you can't get
an exemption to which you were obviously
entitled and i must say in my own
defense i did not mean to suggest that
there's any part of me
that thinks any of the responsibility
here is on you even if you're being too
nice it is the obligation of other human
beings to understand what has to take
place here in order for the right
outcome to occur
these are people who have the power to
write an exemption
yes and somehow are not
providing it to you though
we're literally i mean we're literally
talking about an issue of
your ability not only to earn a living
but to survive
yeah that's
exactly it is a stunning failure
um
these people's obligation to a fellow
human being it just
it boggles the mind
yeah it really does um
you know
do no harm
that is
[Laughter]
stated in the hippocratic oath it just
seems as though it's completely gone out
the window
well not even just out the window but
it's it's it's been inverted
apparently they are willing to do harm
to you the obvious way not to do harm
is to give you this and
um
somehow the legal jeopardy has caused
them to turn it on its head it's
incredible
yeah yeah and like and then it just
continued down this
essentially um
[Music]
windy road of
of
next to my doctor um when i approached
her again to ask for this exemption
she again reiterated no i can't there's
too many legalities around it
um i said can you see though my concern
considering the mandates have just come
in
i can't legally work
the wait time is anywhere from now 11
months to two years um
i don't know i i really i feel like i'm
just stuck in this limbo world now i
don't know what to do
um
[Music]
and she had even said to me
if i were to request her vaccinate me
she would say no
because of my anaphylaxis and that it
was too risky to do it in her practice
now
you haven't told me that before
i mean this is
yeah this is this is
it's kafka ask
right a doctor who knows that she can't
afford to vaccinate you
right i mean at least she has the good
sense not to do that
perhaps for the wrong reason but a
doctor who knows that that your medical
condition does not
allow her to responsibly vaccinate you
cannot write you an exemption that says
it would be irresponsible to vaccinate
this person
i i just don't even i don't understand
i mean really at some level you've just
discovered
a system
in which
all discretion has been removed
and i have to imagine that what's going
on
is that there is such antipathy
for people like myself
who
fear that there are things about these
vaccines that may put anyone in jeopardy
that the desire to prevent folks like us
from finding an exemption has caused
them to remove exemptions from the map
and they're literally putting you in
danger of your life
in order not to grant an exception to
someone else and that
no
no rational system could possibly
function that way it's really you know
they have they have decided to sabotage
their own system because of their anger
at a certain
class of person and
uh i must tell you i mean you and i
obviously aren't in the same system
since i'm american and and you're
australian but
um
to the extent
that
my concerns which i think are legitimate
uh are
causing them to break a system that that
now can't protect you i feel some
responsibility for it i i do and you
know
i don't feel that it would be safe uh to
get the vaccine but certainly i would
probably get away with it i'm in a far
better position to do it than you
um and i i hate that we're being pitted
against each other like this
what what kind of crazy world have we
landed in
it's literally since all this um
i after after hearing that from my
doctor um
she said she would try again
for the
public system
saying you know urgent
this is vaccine-related to see if it
could
progress me in the queue to be seen um
i was quite emotional from all this i
just was not expecting any of this to
happen
i i posted a video on instagram to my
tiny little audience that i have
um essentially just being like
this is my story and
i don't know what to do it doesn't seem
to make any sense to me
um i was just screaming out into the
ether um
and
to my surprise the story blew up it went
viral overnight i had
i had a mix of reactions i actually had
a lot of people in the same boat as me
contact me because of this
and then i also had
some people pull in society saying well
not being aware of that this was going
on to people like me they were shocked
to find out that the people that
supposedly are the ones that they're
getting vaccinated for as the propaganda
is saying
aren't getting granted exemptions or
getting put through the wringer with
this
um
however there were some in society
saying to me
anaphylaxis isn't that bad why don't you
just go get the vaccine
i would i i hope
that the people who said that to you
don't know anything about anaphylaxis
because
the idea that this is something that
because there's a checkbox of what
you're supposed to do when somebody has
an anaphylactic reaction that it's
something that we can just budget for is
obvious nonsense i mean
not only
not only is the anaphylactic reaction
a lethal hazard to you and the treatment
for it not a safe treatment and
a treatment that can fail
but it is also the case that the
vaccines themselves their very nature
causes them
to reprogram elements of your immune
system you're obviously somebody with an
unusual physiology that creates unusual
jeopardy for you
encountering
things in the world
you are the last person who can afford
to have your immune system reprogrammed
in some unpredictable way that might
cause you to become allergic to new
things things that today you don't have
to worry about but a week from today you
might
there is no justification and
i mean i
i will also say
this isn't smallpox
covet is a serious disease but it is not
a disease that kills
healthy people
very regularly and therefore the benefit
that comes from vaccinating a single
person
like you is probably
near zero
the chances that anyone will be
protected especially in a place like
australia that has a low rate of covet
to begin with the chances that any
benefit comes to anyone from doing this
to you is
very very low
and
the risk of harm to you is not only very
high but the harm itself is likely very
extreme
yes
so
every single parameter of your story is
clear
they're all clear there's no reason
you're if you want to test the system to
see
if it could grant an exemption you would
be the perfect case you just check every
box
and see if you get an exemption and if
you don't that says there are no
exemptions
yes
right that's that's a frightening
condition
it is and since all of this they're
um
i guess since i i made my story public
and the video going
viral
it was also picked up by a local um
australian
uh broadcasting news station which gave
me air time to discuss this
who again very similarly similarly to
you um said that this is very clear
clear-cut i am the perfect case to be
granted an exemption
um
but prior to that after seeing my gp as
well i was
then contacted by an organization
which i was never referred to
they're called the victorian specialist
immunization services
as far as i can see they have actually
taken over the immunology clinic at my
treating hospital
i was contacted by one of their nurses
who asked me
who diagnosed me with the polyethylene
glycol allergy and i actually said to
her well your hospital did
and she said oh well i haven't looked
into your file
and she said well let's see how we can
get you in here to vaccinate you safely
which concerned me because i was like
well
there wouldn't be a way
i'm
diagnosed anaphylactic
what i'm seeking is an exemption
and she turned to me and said oh no we
don't give exemptions
this is this is a a person working in a
hospital in a hospital yeah who
actually made the argument that you
should come in have the vaccination
and
if and when you have your reaction they
can treat you with the epinephrine right
then and there
that's correct i mean
obviously it's better than sending you
home but
wow how does how does a medical
professional
fail to understand the jeopardy that
they're putting you to
yeah
yeah and i think this is where like risk
versus benefit has completely gone out
the window because it's
it's like i will i know i have
anaphylactic reactions to these
excipients um anytime i've ingested one
put it on my skin i've always had some
type of reaction the severity
um could be somewhat more mild at times
or somewhat more
severe
um however it's a life risk uh we know
that anaphylaxis is
not a a small
a low a low risk issue it is quite high
it can cause death
um and quickly
as well
um
so to be told that i was just compl that
just spun me out even more
um and i and yeah i was really just
i had no idea where to go
and so i took it to social media with my
video
and then in like this bizarre twist of
fate um someone
although i never mentioned the name of
my doctor um
someone had seen my video
and this is my clinical immunologist the
private one that i was told the uh
weight would be 11 months to see
got me into a
cancellation spot with him
in the next four days
so
if i never made that video
at my wit's end
if it never went viral
this would never have happened
i
i saw him
i gave him all my documentation
um all of the correspondents from my
treating hospital who said that they
didn't look into my file or didn't know
about the polyethylene glycol being
recorded at their hospital i had all
that correspondence i took it with him
my gp also has all this correspondence
um and he literally said to me this is
clear cut you cannot receive these
vaccinations
the possibility of you also you you have
the documented polyethylene glycol
allergy
there's no point in skin prick testing
me for this because i've actually had an
i actually had an anaphylactic reaction
from skin prick testing before which
ended up resulting in me having
epinephrine administered
at my treating hospital from the
polyethylene glycol component
um he said there is no point testing you
for this not to mention also
the issue with skin prick testing is it
can be completely different
when something is injected into your
system
um at a concentrated level as well
your body can react differently so he he
mentioned all this to me and he said the
heart there is a huge potentiality that
the poly i will react to polysorbate 80.
um and given that i have had an
anaphylactic reaction induced by skin
prick testing i
i'm
i'm sort of
it could react quite badly with me just
even getting the testing done for this
so he um
he actually filed that evening my imo11
certificate to the australian
immunization registrar
ticking all the boxes for my permanent
exemption saying that i cannot get these
vaccinations
um
that was lodged three weeks ago
and i still have not received my
exemption
when i have oh sorry no i'm not going to
ask you the obvious question do you have
any idea what's happened
i've called the australian immunization
registrar which are an arm of our
medicare which is
federally run
so this is now out of the hand of the
state government
um
i have called three representatives for
this
um to find out what is going on each
time i've been told a different story
uh the first time i was told that she
could see my exemption in the queue this
was last week
and that they were backlogged however
they were up today
they were up to the date of october 20th
to process mine was submitted on october
26th so it shouldn't take too much
longer
still hadn't received anything
yesterday i phoned them again in the
morning
they actually stated to me that they
got the exemption however it was
illegible to read
so they requested that my doctor send a
new one
which was then received on november the
2nd
and i'm being placed back in the queue
now wait a minute
i
mean i think i'm fairly good at spotting
[ __ ] and i think i i may have
spotted a healthy dose of [ __ ] here
because
this suggests the fact that there is a
cue and that yes well we can see yours
in it and we are working our way towards
it suggests that exemptions are being
granted
now if exemptions are being granted
what the hell have you encountered
what why are you having such trouble
getting the system to recognize the
obvious need for you to have one or are
they just telling you that exemptions
are being granted as a stalling tactic
so once they go through this process
although your doctor may write the
exemption
it doesn't mean that you're granted it
the government can still deny it
right but
again betty look either there's a
discretionary process somewhere where
some human being gets to put an eyeball
on an application and say you know what
this one's just clear-cut let's grant
the exemption or there isn't a process
and the point is well there really
aren't any exemptions but we can't very
well say that can we
and i can't
it would seem if there is an actual
process of exemptions
then
you shouldn't have faced any of this
and if there's no process of exemptions
then what are they telling you
right that it's in a queue i mean maybe
maybe you've nailed it maybe the idea is
oh yes we haven't gotten around to
rejecting your exemption yet we've still
got many ahead of you that need to be
rejected maybe that's what they're
saying
i mean it's really you know it's it's a
it's a customer service nightmare is
what you're facing um
where
something doesn't want to give you
something you're entitled to and so it's
going to come up with every excuse
and
um
i'm
without words
yeah it's been um the the phone
conversations i had yesterday especially
in hearing that it was requested that my
doctor sent a legible copy considering
the first representative that i spoke to
read to me that she could read
my exemption she saw it she read out
what was on it so
that sounded like it was legible to me i
was confused when this second
representative said that it was
illegible
so i contacted my private doctor again
who said no there was no request for a
second form to be sent
so they told you that they had requested
a legible one because the one they got
was illegible and the person
to whom they would have made that
request had not gotten a request
yes
well that does sound like what would
happen if they were
bullshitting yes it does
it does it seems to unravel a lot of
this um
yeah this this messy ball of twine that
has now been put in front of me yeah
so
i rang them again
um
[Music]
and i got another representative
who said that now i had
they could see that i had two forms so
one that was submitted on the 26th and
one that was submitted on the second
now i was like i'm very confused because
my doctor has said that they haven't
sent a second they actually asked me
would they like me would they want me to
send
one so i said to this representative i'm
very confused why do you have two
documents and who are they from
and he looked at both and said to me
they're from the same doctor i said well
how do you have two when my doctor
hasn't
sent a second i said unless it was
because my doctor had faxed one
and sent one by mail at the same time
and he said that could be the reason i
said well then why did this
representative earlier tell me that a
second one had been requested because
the first was illegible it seems like a
made-up story now
and i said so what's going to be getting
processed
and he literally said he didn't know
he did not know if my and i said well
i'm told that the one on the 26
because also the earlier representative
told me now that they're up to the 29th
of october so clearly my one on the 26
didn't get
approved
so now i must wait for my set one on the
2nd of november to be approved
yet when i spoke to this third
representative he said oh no we're not
up to the 29th we're only up to the 26.
it's
it's
it's unbearable it's
unbearable where did the humans go
[Laughter]
you're obviously dealing with some kind
of
human looking
human sounding
drone
i i can't
there's
i
i wish i knew what to say i really have
the sense that even in a very broken and
this is this has been my experience even
in a very broken system there is
generally somebody
who upon seeing a story like yours
would know the way to make it work out
right somebody would recognize the
necessity the importance here and
somebody
for whatever reason because basic human
decency would say ah you need to file a
form
22-7
38 b
right and you've got to send it to this
office and not that office and then they
can send back a such and such
and yet
you've clearly
you've
made enough inquiries you've been to
enough places you've talked to enough
people
that there just doesn't seem to be
anyone who can who can staunch the
bleeding
yeah it's incredible and speaking of
staunching bleeding
um
i know from the time we spoke before
that
anaphylaxis is not the only
medically unusual parameter from your
condition and the others at least one of
them is relevant to these vaccinations
and the possible
hazard that they pose to you
and you want to say something about that
yeah so my um again my clinical
immunologist um
stressed especially at the fact of
clearly i'm going to have anaphylaxis
to both of the mrna vaccines
is a high probability of having it um to
the astrazeneca due to the polysorbate
80 cross reactivity his other concern
with the astrazeneca
is um the fact that i do have a bleeding
condition as well it can be linked in
with the ehlers-danlos syndrome
um
there are different types of values down
loss you can have it's uh my doctor has
suspected that i possibly have a
condition called classical as i have
issues with heavy bleeding um issues
um i get concurrent nosebleeds out of
nowhere where sometimes i will use three
block boxes of kleenex just on one
random nosebleed if i cut myself
i bleed a lot i bruise very easily my
skin is quite soft and
stretchy again another condition of this
um
splitting skin
my lips on a regular basis swell up
especially if i'm having an allergic
reaction and they will just start
bleeding my gums bleed daily
um i have heavy menstrual um
cycles
i've actually another concern of his was
that um because i am a migraine sufferer
i have been placed on the contraceptive
pill multiple in the past i was actually
rushed to the er one night with a
suspected
blood clot as i had a stroke-like
episode where half of my body went numb
on the left-hand side my face drooped
my eye my vision got impaired and i was
slurring my words
um
i had a
uh um emergency mri and i was told that
i could not take the contraceptive pill
for this reason i also hemorrhaged for
two months straight due to it
so this has all been a concern
as well
with especially the astrozenica
vaccination um and the side effects from
that
well so obviously this is an entirely
other
independently sufficient reason that it
would be absurd in the case of a disease
like covid and vaccines like these which
are not especially effective do not
prevent people from contracting covet or
transmitting it
this is another independently sufficient
reason that you should obviously be
exempted
um
so
what what is the state of the story now
you're just simply waiting to see if
this magical
cue ever advances to the point that a
legible copy of
your application makes it to a person
with the rubber stamp
or
what is it
i
i guess so that is all i'm doing i i'm
awaiting
this exemption
to come in
um
over here we have a
um we have a tick system so in your
government account which links our
our australian tax office um our
medicare our center link our health
records um
all under one umbrella in this
government app
we all have to download which will show
our green tick of approval which we can
use to
work
um
attend venues shop
in
society this is um
so when the exam exemption is granted
this will appear on our phone so or when
you get your double covered vaccination
this will appear on your phone and you
can use it
um now a couple of weeks ago i actually
did speak to a doctor from this vic cis
company
um
they have called me on a private number
there is no return phone line for
um this service
given that i said that i was uh awaiting
a permanent exemption because she called
me after i spoke to my um
my private allergist
i said i am waiting to receive my
permanent exemption she said in the
meantime do you have anything in your my
gov to prove
that you cannot get these vaccinations i
said no i don't she said well i will
upload a temporary exemption and when
your permanent comes in that will
override the temporary
she uploaded into my mygov that i have a
contraindication to both mrna vaccines
but not the astrazeneca so i do not have
a legal
exemption
uploaded into
my mygov account i have a
contraindication for one month
to tour the vaccinations i do not know
how long this process is going to take
to be granted
this
permanent exemption i was told by
medicare
when i asked them if they knew who had
accessed my
access to my file to upload this they
said they could not see who it was
from my end i cannot see who it is
um there is no contact number for this
this department the vixis
um
[Music]
so i cannot even contact this woman
to
[Music]
know
what this exactly means where the third
um
contraindication is in my my gov
[Music]
so
yeah so and from this as well um
our
in victoria
we are under a state of emergency
by our
state government
there is a bill that is getting par
getting pushed through parliament
the bill is the
public health and wellbeing amendment
the pandemic management bill
this is to come into effect if it passes
by
december 16.
in this bill
it could literally
be used
to say that people with an exemption
it is not valid
it could invalidate exemptions that have
been legally granted
yes
it is
essentially this bill can declare
a permanent pandemic status
in our state of victoria
even when there is no covert present in
the state or the country
what could possibly go wrong
so
all right we will return to the question
of what
an ominous provision like that implies
about the state of
victoria and
of the west
there is a last piece of your story i
hope we haven't skipped anything but you
mentioned something that i didn't know
about a new development uh in the story
do you want to mention that are you are
you at liberty to do so
um
in regards sorry in regards to uh you
mentioned a raid that had taken place oh
yes um
so as of yesterday
a family doctor in a local
doctor's surgery located in melbourne
he's been a practicing doctor for 30
years
yesterday he was raided by the
department of health and human services
or the dhhs
by seven
officials
um
he was rated um
it was shared on the mainstream media it
has also been shared on an independent
um
journalist site an independent
journalist was actually present to film
the whole scenario
uh as they rated him they said it was
due to him giving out exemptions to
people
like myself
i have never seen this doctor however
given everything going on
i had multiple people including my legal
representative say to me go and find a
new gp who will grant you the exemption
again your case being clear-cut
me feeling as though as well
i do have an extensive history it's not
as simple as me just finding a gp and
having a 10 minute consultation
someone had actually mentioned to me
this doctor may be able to help me
um
[Music]
the person actually that gave me the
contact number was someone in a
political party in australia
um when i phoned his
receptionist i was told he's not
accepting new patients and that is fair
enough that has been said for quite a
few doctors
so
um i just left it at that
yesterday i found out via the news that
this exact doctor had been raided by the
dhhs
what they had done they have taken
all the private patient documents
um
all of their health records
they have seized them they have seized
his log books for his
um for any of his appointments in his
appointment book
they were harassing his receptionist
asking what her vaccination status was
um
and
he is not allowed to practice
at the moment due to this and this all
eventuated yesterday
wow now obviously there could be
something
about this doctor's story that that you
don't know there could be something that
justifies that kind of intervention on
the other hand it certainly does seem
consistent with the world in which
i certainly know uh
here in the us that doctors
who uh are alarmed by the adverse event
signal associated with the vaccines
are under
intense pressure
to do things that do not seem to be
in their
correct medical judgment
so
you know there's
there's also the possibility that this
is just simply authoritarianism
marching through your medical structure
and uh punishing
and
um blocking the action of doctors who
are using their own judgment and
deciding who needs an exemption which is
of course exactly what you would want a
doctor to do to evaluate an individual
case and say yes this person needs an
exemption that person doesn't need an
exemption that's that's the system
functioning and here
uh it may well have triggered uh a raid
and the capturing of
private citizens medical files by the
government
so i guess that that brings us to the
question you know i i certainly hope
that this
broadcast
reaches whoever needs to be reached in
australia and that the sheer
embarrassment of your terrifying story
causes at the very least
your individual case to be resolved in a
way that protects your health as best we
can collectively do so
i also hope that anyone else who needs
an exemption
finds one because this story causes
the the necessary discretion to be
restored to the system so that
it does not generate tragedy after
tragedy and podcast after podcast about
terrifying
losses of the ability to earn
for example and just for starters i mean
really at some level
you are being
placed in a predicament
where
your livelihood will be lost if you do
not accept a vaccination that puts your
life in jeopardy
and
if you
do not take this life jeopardizing
vaccination
you lose
a substantial fraction of your natural
rights as a citizen
your right to move about freely
your right to earn a living
you become a partial prisoner in your
home
and
that is simply
perfectly inconsistent
with the rights that the founders of the
western way of life
uh recognized you have the right to live
normally and there's nothing
about this pandemic
that justifies this level of
authoritarianism
and to have this level of
authoritarianism pushing
vaccines of such low quality
and such dubious
safety
especially pushing them towards somebody
with such vulnerability
really reveals the entire problem
the system is absolutely out of control
we citizens don't know what it's about
but we can tell from your story and many
others that we are dealing with customer
service we are not dealing with a public
health apparatus we are not dealing with
government in any normal sense we are
dealing with customer service which
wishes to deny us something and will
give us every excuse in the book in
order to do so
and i
uh
i did not think we would ever find
ourselves here i mean just think about
the
the fact of us having this discussion
um
across you know across a diagonal
over the pacific ocean
that we should have to talk about
the failure of the west because nothing
else captures a failure that stretches
from australia to north america
to europe
it it's it's remarkable and
uh
i i wish i wish i knew what it was we
were supposed to do next i do have the
sense that many people
died to provide us the liberties that we
are now losing and that that is supposed
to be capturing our attention in a way
that it has not yet
yeah it feels quite surreal especially
when um
poland was even offering
that it's dual citizens
who were living in victoria
essentially refuge over in poland to get
out of our state
due to what is going on over here when
we're having
the
you know
the the polish embassy saying things
like that it's what have we become as
you know a first world westernized
country where our citizens are needing
to seek refuge elsewhere
because our home state is illivable
this is this is terrifying um
as as a jew i'm 52 years old
when i was a kid
the holocaust seemed like ancient
history i of course now as an adult know
that it was not that it was very recent
but i certainly
was led to understand
by my elders my elders who had seen the
holocaust
that it could happen
anywhere and that one needed to be alert
to the fact that this authoritarian
menace
can emerge that this is a defect in the
human psyche and the fact that things
seem
to be humming along at one moment does
not mean that you don't need to be aware
of the possibility because it can emerge
at any time
what no one
ever alerted me to and what i think
no one ever contemplated
was that it could happen everywhere at
once
that's a terrifying possibility and
i am
struck by the fact that australia
is certainly one of the places that
would have been highest on my list of
places to run to
if my own country had ever
done this
i am now watching
i know two people personally one an
individual and one uh
the father of a a family who are
literally
fleeing australia they've sold what they
have and they are doing everything in
their power to get out
because the authoritarian and
authoritarianism
is uh clearly advancing and nobody knows
where it stops
i don't know what it's going to take
to wake us up but i think the fact is
this isn't exactly what we were warned
about but it's clearly a close relative
of it
yeah it it has completely i guess
blindsided quite a lot of us and we're
there was still all this talk through i
guess especially 2020
and leading into 2021 especially with
the reopening over our summer
before we went into our um
our more recent snap
seven day lockdown which lasted
seven months
um
that
you know things were on the up and up
possibly we're going back to reopening
our economy has completely suffered from
this over here nearly every
every second store here is felice um
people are
you know leaving our state of victoria
actually has the highest
number of people who have left
to other areas whether it be other
countries or other states
but the rate of victorians especially
leaving due to the fact that we are the
most locked down
lockdown place in the world with the
hardest lockdowns as well
um is that is that true i did not know
that that was a formal fact you have the
most stringent lockdowns of anywhere on
earth
yeah and for the longest time
and
what explanation are you given for that
it's for our health
it's it's that's
it's literally all
over i don't really watch mainstream
media um but when i get glimpses of it
it still seems that it's being
propagated that this is all
for health um
[Music]
however when i'm someone with a
allergy like anaphylaxis and i'm being
told to get the vaccination that will
induce anaphylaxis it doesn't seem like
it's for health at all
um
it's it's you know the the mental health
impacts that this is creating
um
is almost not even allowed to be a
discussion anymore it's almost like
we've gone backward and mental health
has now become another taboo as
it
it
it's just it's quite insane to see where
we are especially in our
state i know personally i can exp um
express this story we had we lost a
property due to this
we had a property
um in the city of melbourne
um this is me and my mother
and we actually sold it at a loss
because we could not get it tenanted for
over a year due to the lockdowns
so we sold it
due to this and
lost profit
uh not even profit we actually lost of
what we spent on the property
but we just
it was it was costing us more
to even keep it
you lost the property you lost the value
of the property you didn't even just
have to sell it
is that what you're telling me yeah so
this is having
drastic impacts on
your
financial
situation
so
were you
to try to survive
without earning a living
this is also now eroding
what you had acquired
that which might have helped you get
through this period however long it's
supposed to be and you know i think i
think you
you made the point very clearly just a
moment ago
you're being told that this is for your
health
but obviously you're the proof that that
can't possibly be right
if this was about health
then an exemption for you would be a top
priority
the fact that an exemption for you
has
so far not emerged and that you've been
put through the ringer in the pursuit of
it
suggests that this is definitely about
something else and i i must say i have
the very same feeling
here in the u.s i look at our public
health policy and it is
almost to a measure
the inverse of what we should be doing
if we wish to control this pandemic to
prevent people from getting sick to
reduce the severity of their illness to
reduce the chances that they will
transmit it to others we are doing
almost the inverse of what would be
right and i think your story has also
this characteristic it is the inverse of
what you would expect if this was about
health
so
i don't know what to make of that other
than i think we are still in search of
the answer of what this is actually
about
and you know presumably most of the
people doing this don't have
don't have any
sorry
presumably most of the people doing this
don't have any idea themselves they're
just functioning as automatons
they're cogs in a system but someone
knows
and i think it's about time we found out
yeah i think so because it it's making
it impossible to even plan
plan a future or plan next week
especially our legislation keeps
changing
literally on a daily basis
even the exemption
process
um
changed
last week um
after
i i
had an appearance
on sky news australia and then the next
day the legislation around exemptions
changed as a directive from our chief
health officer in
victoria as well
making it stricter for exemptions prior
to that
a letter from your gp was granted as an
exemption that you could legally use in
society
however coming in effect of november the
12th so tomorrow those letters are now
void
wow
and uh what can you tell me as we're
wrapping up here um what can you tell me
about
how
the australian public
understands this i see periodically when
i go and i look at
sources of news that aren't necessarily
mainstream
i see quite a bit of unrest
and i of course know as i mentioned
before
these stories of my friends who are
fleeing
that paints one kind of picture
and then one gets a very different sort
of picture if one looks at mainstream
sources what's it like on the ground
it's
we have
protests
on a regular basis here um
nationwide
especially in our home
state in victoria specifically in
melbourne
um
the protest numbers are growing and
there has been a lot of um i guess the
mainstream sources usually
saying that participants are
far right extremists or
neo-nazis or anti-vaxx conspiracy
theorists what have you that's
generally what it gets painted as we do
have a few
on the ground um
live stream
journalists who will film the entire
um protest and exactly what's going on
and speak to the people
we're actually having protests recently
now led
by opposition leaders
of the parliament we are
we are a labor-run state we are having
um other parties
and
um representatives from our liberal
government
speaking out about this new pandemic
legislation getting put forward
the numbers in the protests are growing
they're getting um
they're happening more regularly
the people aren't happy with what's
going on in the state and they don't
feel
like
our best interest
is at heart
um especially given this new
bill that is being put forward
um
we're even having as i said politicians
leading the way in these protests giving
speeches on the stairs of parliament
um
there has been during the the lockdowns
as things have started to reopen
um
our police force are walking alongside
protesters
as you know just to make sure that it's
all kept
i guess um so the police are not
supportive they're there
i don't know you would have to guess i
would imagine but are they there to
intimidate or
well um
currently our police seem to be
they seem to be there to control in case
a scenario got
out of hand
however
only as of a couple of weeks ago
protests were not allowed in our state
so the police force being present
were not only there to intimidate but
they were
essentially
uh antagonizing um they were rocking up
in riot gear
there was tear gas grenades there were
rubber bullets being pelted we're an
unarmed society
um
they were being pelted with
rubber bullets
um
yeah
rubber bullets which sounds a lot like
nicer than it is uh rubber bullets are
quite quite dangerous we saw some of the
footage from some of the people that
actually got hit with them and there was
skin broken and there was blood
there were mounted police all over the
city this is what our you know
our our taxpayers money is going on yes
your enlightened society has broken down
into
the stigmatizing of protesters as what
did you say you said conspiracy
theorists right wingers anti-vaxxers
and neo-nazis
yes um
interesting i've been accused of all of
those things even though each of them
yeah maybe not neo-nazi i've certainly
been accused of being a nazi um
but i'm i'm in each case the opposite of
that
who um
who
are the protesters if if those labels
are fiction
who
who if you went to the protest and you
interviewed people what kind of folks
would you find
you would find like and this is the
thing i think you know in any group you
may find some of those subgroups so you
may find the ones who
are potentially more on the anti-vax
spectrum or i i couldn't really say i
don't think i've ever met a neo-nazi so
i wouldn't be able to describe them
they're pretty rare these days
um however most of them are just general
citizens most of them are
fearful of their children's future a lot
of them especially given that they are
now taught and and some people are
fearful as well of the fact that
um
the mandates are coming into effect into
schools as well so kids are going to
need to be vaccinated to be able to
attend school
parents are worried about this given the
nature of these rushed vaccinations and
how safe it may be and and most of these
parents they're not anti-vaxxers they
have i've spoken to them they've said i
have vaccinated my kid with other
vaccinations this this is exactly where
i am i i will not have my children
vaccinated with these vaccines because
there's no medical reason to do it right
they're a danger to these kids and these
kids have essentially i mean a healthy
child has essentially no risk from cobit
my children are healthy but uh we have
we have vaccinated our children
completely in fact beyond what most
families do because we've traveled with
them to places that have some fairly
exotic pathogens and we've gotten them
vaccinations
i personally when i was a professor used
to lecture on the beauty of
vaccination and how it works right the
idea of informing the immune system
about an enemy that no ancestor of yours
has seen
and that being a way to get a jump on
the infection so it never gets to the
point of making you sick i still think
that's incredibly beautiful
but
that doesn't mean that every component
of the vaccines is beautiful it doesn't
mean that any given vaccine is safe it
doesn't mean any of these things and
were you to make an argument like well
vaccines are safe it implies that the
system
that checks whether they're safe is
extremely well protected from corruption
which it isn't
we have a system we know to be corrupt
exactly and i think this has literally
shown a light on that um
especially for myself i you know
i could see some things happening
however when it directly impacted me in
this exemption process i didn't actually
realize the can of worms i was going to
be opening
with this
and to see the overreach of government
i've actually had politicians who i
reached out to
messaging me back saying it's a real
shame
but doctors are unable to even be
doctors
it's it they're making it almost
impossible
here
with this overreach
it's
um
you know i've had some private
information seen
medical information
um
expressed to me by a third party that i
have never spoken to before who have
known some
personal private information about my
medical history and i was not sure where
they had gotten this
when i spoke to my legal representative
i was literally told it's the government
if they want to know anything about you
they can
which
seems like of a violation of our rights
and privacy we have acts and bills in
place to protect us as citizens from
this happening yeah it's it's like a
combination
of every
great dystopian narrative
right it's like you don't know whether
it's kafka
or it's orwell
or you're in brazil
or your your story about your
vaccination
status in your phone app reminds me of
logan's run i you know i i don't know
what movie i'm in but i know it ain't a
good one
right
yes exactly even the fact that now you
can't plead ignorance here either if
you're not up to date with the recent
cho
directives which again like i said they
literally change them on a daily basis
you have to tune in in the morning and
watch it on the mainstream media or on
your tablet or where have you to know
what the new rules and regulations are
and you cannot plead ignorant if you
were
doing the wrong thing the wrong thing in
society which is not following a cho
directive
um
you can
um
face a penalty you can face a fine and
it does seem very much like that tuning
in
like we have seen in 1984 to big brother
in the morning and
it is
it does seem very much like that and
yeah
well all right um
two final points one i keep looking at
what's taking place in australia and i
keep checking in with the part of me
that
two years ago would have said ah that
would be exactly the place to go if you
ever needed shelter from
authoritarianism elsewhere in the west
and realizing well i guess i had that
wrong
but i also wonder if you're not six
months ahead of us because of the
inversion of the seasons
you were of course in spring
we are here in autumn
and this is a seasonal disease
so i very much hope that i am wrong
but i do wonder if we will look at
ourselves in six months and see
things that mirror what you all are
facing
down under
at this moment i very much hope that
that's not the case but i fear it might
be
now finally
when we spoke in preparation for this
i suggested that you get
a twitter account so that people could
follow your story now i very much hope
that people will sign up and i hope that
the embarrassment that your government
officials and your medical establishment
feel upon having your story spread
around the world will cause them
to remedy at least your one case right
away and then to address the others that
surely sound something like yours other
people who are deserving of exemptions
that they cannot get
so
your twitter handle do you know it
i do know it yes
all right well you're ahead of many
people
um so it's betty sarah so it's spelt b e
t t y
s e r a
number three
betty sarah
number three on twitter and you said you
also are on instagram
i am on instagram yep under betty sarah
as well so b-e-t-t-y-s-e-r-a
that is sarah and um
i i'm about to make an embarrassing
admission at least it will become
obvious um
do you want to remind me how to
pronounce your last name
sure it's pezzamenti
betty pezzamanti betty sarah pesimenti
i'm presuming is that right that's
correct yep betty sarah pezzamenti and
your business is
the earthly sweet spot
that's correct is that correct well i
hope that your business flourishes i
hope that your exemption arrives with a
gigantic
bouquet of flowers and a
government-sized apology for all of the
nonsense you've been put through
i am incredibly appreciative of
both your grace in facing this
authoritarian nonsense
and your willingness to share it
so that we all can benefit from
the uh
ongoing tragedy and absurdity that
you're faced with
betty
thank you so much for doing it and i
really hope good news is just around the
corner
thank you so much bretton for this
opportunity um yeah i really hope i
could be the voice for many in the world
as well
all right well good luck to you and good
luck to everyone down under
thank you and likewise be well
thanks bye
all right um that was great it's going
to take us a little bit of time to edit
it
okay yep but i'm really i'm happy with
how it went there are a few things i
stumbled over but that's just the nature
of the beast and uh
anyway it's an incredible story and um
i really uh i meant what i said at the
end i think um
you're you're quite marvelous and that
it takes something to face this kind of
bleak
lethal
nonsense
with uh a smile on your face and
um you know uh
a hopeful tone in your voice so anyway
you're you're a model for the rest of us
and i i greatly appreciate it
thank you brett i think um
i'll just say like i think what's
driving me um
if i don't get too emotional um
my father passed away in a melbourne
hospital due to medical negligence
it was a court battle we only won last
year after seven years
and i think this is what's perpetuate
sorry
perpetuating me forward
um
i pray to him every day to give me
strength for this um
we were so we had to sign an nda to say
that we could not disclose
his court case or tarnish the name of
the public health system because of it
um we settled out a court and we won um
during the process my mum had a heart
attack
we lost our family home
and we also lost my grandmother and
um
it's in his name that i will not let it
go in vain and i will fight for what's
right and especially when it comes to
the health and freedoms of others
well i am
proud and honored
to fight alongside you that's a terrible
terrible story and
uh obviously an appalling price
to pay for
medical negligence and i i can't imagine
what that must have been
like
um
i mean really
what can one even say there's no there's
no
there's no compensation or
consolation that one could find after
such a loss and
i'm sorry that happened
yeah
thank you it's um you know it
it showed me a lot of what
can happen
i guess um
and what if a
health system or a government want to
make you shut up and go away and try and
hide things they can
however it's not okay and sometimes it's
not until something happens when it's
too late and nothing will bring a person
back
[Music]
[Music]
you